in other videos we touched on the notion
of kinetic molecular theory which i'll
just shorten as kmt and it's just this
idea that if you imagine a container
i'll just draw it in two dimensions here
that it contains some gas
you can imagine the gas as being these
particles where their collective volume
is much smaller than the volume of the
container and the temperature we're
dealing with is related to the average
kinetic energy of the particles these
particles are all moving around zooming
around and they have some they each
would have some kinetic energy remember
kinetic energy you calculate that as m v
squared over two so each of these
particles would have some mass and some
velocity but they could all have
different velocities for sure even if
they're the same type of particle and if
they're different types of particles
they can have different masses as well
but the average of these kinetic
energies across all of these particles
that is proportional to temperature when
measured in kelvin and pressure the
pressure remember pressure is nothing
but force per unit area and so you can
imagine this surface of our container
this could be some type of a cube so i
can draw it in three dimensions here so
there's some area
over here
and you have your particles let me do
this in a different color these
particles are constantly bouncing off of
it and there's way more particles than
what i have drawn here so at any given
moment you're having some particles that
are bounced off bouncing off of this
side of the container actually all sides
of the container and these are perfectly
elastic collisions they're preserving
kinetic energy and so they're applying
some force collectively on this area so
the pressure is because of these
particle collisions on the surface
now what i want to do in this video is
take these ideas that we conceptualize
in kinetic molecular theory and to
understand why the ideal gas law pv
is equal to n rt
makes sense when we conceptualize the
world here just a reminder p is pressure
v is volume n is the number of moles of
whatever gas we're dealing with the
amount of that gas and then t is the
temperature in kelvin and r is just the
ideal gas constant that's just whatever
constant you're doing so that the units
all work out together
so let's first think about how pressure
relates to volume if we were to hold
everything else constant
well the ideal gas law tells us that
pressure times volume
is going to be equal to this if we hold
it constant i could even just write a k
here for a constant but that would also
mean we could divide let's say both
sides by v we could say that pressure is
equal to some constant over v another
way to think about it is is that
pressure is proportional to the inverse
of volume you could also write this if
we divide both sides by p is that volume
is proportional to the inverse of
pressure does that make sense from a
kinetic molecular theory point of view
pause this video and think about it
well imagine
we have our original cube right over
here and i have the same number of
particles they have the same average
kinetic energy but let's say i were to
increase the volume
so if i were to make the volume go up so
i would somehow expand this or maybe put
the exact number the same particles with
the same temperature and a larger
container
and then in any given moment you're just
going to have fewer bounces of particles
off of the container because they just
have more room to go in that volume and
even the surface area of the container
is going to be high as well so it makes
sense that if the volume goes up the
pressure is going to go down and you
could think about it the other way if
you make this smaller that same number
of particles with the same average
kinetic energy there's going to bump
into the container that much more often
and that's going to increase the
pressure so volume goes down pressure
goes up
and this relationship that pressure is
inversely proportional to volume or vice
versa if you hold everything else
constant that's often known as boyle's
law
now another relationship what if we were
to hold volume and the number of moles
constant and we want to think about the
relationship between pressure and
temperature
well if this is constant this constant
this is constant the ideal gas law would
say that pressure is going to be
proportional to temperature or that
temperature is proportional to pressure
does that make sense well let's go back
to our original container
if you were to increase the temperature
that means that the average kinetic
energy is increased that means that
these particles when they hit the side
of the container they're going to hit it
with more velocity that means that
they're going to have at any given
moment you're going to have more
pressure exerted on the side of the
container and you could go the other way
think about lowering the temperature so
the kinetic energy goes really low then
these particles are just slowly drifting
and the speed with which they are
hitting the side of the container is
going to go down and so the pressure
would go down so it completely makes
sense if temperature goes up pressure
goes up if temperature goes down
pressure goes down and this is known
often known as guy lusak's law
now another relationship and i'm really
just going through all of the
combinations over here what if we were
to hold pressure on the number of
molecules constant so we're really
looking at the relationship between
volume and temperature so once again if
p n and r is always constant if those
are constant the ideal gas law would
tell us that the volume is proportional
to the temperature once again holding
everything else constant well to think
about that you can go through that same
thought experiment we just had we want
to if we increase the temperature if
these things are moving around faster if
you want to have the same amount of
force per area on the container on the
side of the container you're going to
have to increase the volume so this
relationship which is completely
consistent with kinetic molecular theory
is often known as charles's law
now another one is the relationship
between volume and the number of moles
if everything else is held constant the
ideal gas law would tell us that volume
is going to be proportional to
the number of moles of our particle or
of our gas that we are dealing with and
that makes sense because once again
you're holding everything else constant
you want pressure to be constant
temperature to be constant if i were to
double the number of particles here but
i don't want to change the pressure of
the temperature it makes sense that i
would have to double the volume likewise
if i wanted to double the volume here
and i didn't want to change the pressure
of the temperature i would have to put
twice as many particles in there so i
still have sufficient number of
interactions of bouncing of the
particles with the sides of the
container so that i have the sufficient
pressure and this notion is called
avogadro's law last but not least let's
say i have two identical containers
if i have two identical containers
that's one there
that's one
over here and actually i'm gonna draw
that same container a third time
and let's say over here
i have gas 1
and it has some partial or in this case
it has some pressure due to gas 1. we're
going to assume the volume and the
temperatures are the same across all
three of these and let's say we have gas
2
and it is exerting
pressure to if i were to take all of the
gas in both of them and put them both
into this third container so this third
container is going to have all of the
original of gas 1 and all of the
original of gas 2
but we aren't changing the volume and we
aren't changing the temperature in any
given unit area on the surface of the
container you're going to get the
collisions from particle 1 which would
give you p1 in that that force per unit
area and you're going to get the
collisions from particle 2 which would
give you that force per unit area so it
makes sense that the partial pressures
would add up to be equal to the total
pressure in the container and this is
known as dalton's law but the whole
point of this video is just to
appreciate that everything we've talked
about with the ideal gas law actually
makes a lot of sense i would argue it
makes the most sense when you think
about it in terms of kinetic molecular
theory